this video is sponsored by Babel more on
them after the reaction
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we have just been
in a much lighthearted Fair mood so we
have decided that we are going to watch
this movie today thank you for
recommending it easya a starring Emma
Stone AKA America's national treasure
featuring Nicholas Cage John you who
said you've read the book that this is
based on or something I did once in high
school I actually read The Scarlet
Letter I don't know what that is and I
have no clue what this movie is about
but I do love Emma Stone and everything
I have ever seen her in so I'm excited
to see it guys we got a lot lined up for
the month of December and probably going
to be getting all the way into January
so please go ahead leave a like on this
video that'd be very much appreciated be
sure to subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when a
reaction for something is up that Peaks
your interest thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
and as always full length R and watch
along that's where you sync up with your
own copy that is available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
over there we cover several things
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included John are you finally
ready to see the adaptation you have
been chomping at the bit to see this
whole time I got a few more things to
say if you don't mind I do mind I got a
oh all right fine just shut up
[Music]
this looks familiar oh it's
ohigh hey I've been to oh
high someone's selling
drugs oh Mana B his
hey and use pen badg Le that's a
creative use of the credits it's like
playing Waldo with credits if Google
Earth were a guy he couldn't find me if
I was dressed up as a 10 story
building mhm what does it all mean why
am I
here Lisa cudro and Malcolm McDow though
it sure started out that way and then it
changed pretty quickly when I started
lying about some very personal things
uhoh okay that I Olive Pendergast being
of sound mind and below average breast
size oh no here to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
all right starting
now and what better way to share my
private thoughts than to broadcast them
on the Internet and Emma Stone the
shutter inducing and cliche however
totally false account of how I lost my
virginity to a guy at a community
college what oh No George is like what
you name your teddy bear not the name
you want to scream out during climax
I assume you mean the stable and
self-perpetuating end stage is the
evolution of a plant Community yeah but
I don't say it out loud L someone get
the wrong idea I think you know inuendo
is attached to everything these days
inuendo what whatever do you mean
[Music]
Ranon hugs not drugs mess with the bull
get the horns and any other cliches you
can come up with I love a good cliche
yeah buddy here is where the trouble
began the lie that started the whole
thing I cannot go camping with you okay
I'm sorry but I have a date with who you
don't know him then neither do you you
selfish [__] he goes to college with my
brother okay what's his name then he
lives in Canada a couple weeks ago she
asked me to come camping with her family
and I don't know why I didn't want to go
a little because I didn't really feel
like hanging out with her all weekend
what is this credits Choice
yeah and I live in California I ate
dinner at her house once and I swore
never again this is interesting pachuli
Burger we grew it in our victory garden
[Music]
thank you I'm trying to watch my figure
beautiful well I'm
not wardrobe tape doing its job boy I
lied and told her I couldn't go because
I had a date with a friend of my
brothers named George let's just face it
there is no such thing as a sexy George
George Clooney George Soros George
Lazenby dude James B George Miller and
here's how I really spent the
weekend
worst song
ever don't be
hating suuck in your
head very much my high school music
cycle
so accurate late
afternoon secet
[Music]
place so accurate who whoa wait a minut
what you didn't have no no of course not
you liar you totally lost your Fe card
to him no I didn't yes you did no R I'm
not that kind of girl oh really the kind
that does it or the kind that does it
and doesn't have the lady balls to tell
her best friend you know exact what you
meant how are you guys best friends I
want every detail now [__] face you're
not really heading in the right
direction with that one tell
me we did it
yes oh no now you're super [__] like me
I don't think letting Peter headin
motorboat you behind a Bed Bath and
Beyond really makes you a super [__] an
intermediate [__] whatever this isn't
about me this is about you would you let
him do it was normal be
Vivid great detail
I don't know why I did it I guess maybe
it was because it was the first time I
had sort of felt Superior to re but I
just started piling on lie after lie it
was like setting up Jenga it's a good
device I know what it's like C he was
sweet it's going to
spread oh Manda please what the hell are
you looking at Sister Christian just a
couple of admitted oh Sister Christian
indeed Maryanne Bryant is the secretary
of the student council and the president
of the cross your heart club a club
dedicated to shoving their beliefs down
people's throats as it should be that's
their faith amen give it up for your
very own Blue
Devil Blue
Devil this is the work of the
devil how can we exhibit school pride
when we're conveyed to others as Satan
worshippers now thankfully we are them
much less intimidating who AR in
heaven oh
[Music]
no that's a
beaver I like Todd much better when he
was topless but even dressed as a
woodchuck I still fantasize about
him you could get it ouch now marann had
a new C CB me which brings us to part
two the accelerated velocity of
terminological inexactitude which is
really just my obnoxious way of saying
that lies travel fast good my
terminological inexactitude accelerate
with
velocity good turns of phrase in this
movie I really like the directing of it
and the um the editing of it is solid
there's like real style with a definite
yeah visual style and language sharp
Rhythm and stuff
[Music]
yeah oh no oh oh no word travels fast
wow the anxieties of high school can I
uh talk to you alone for a second can
you be okay yeah I'm fine thank you she
totally has given her flower away yep
Olive that's your name right yeah and
you're Maryanne uh we've had nine
classes together since kindergarten 10
if you count religion of other cultures
which you didn't because you called it
science fiction and refused to go oh
yeah amen I hope for you your sake that
God has a sense of humor oh I have 17
years worth of anecdotal proof he does
ye I just hope for your sake that you've
cleaned the
sheets got to wash them every week for
the first time ever my sexual exlo were
the talk of the school oh you know what
I'm wrong it was the second time the
first time was back in 8th grade when
all I wanted was a kiss from this guy i'
always had a crush on no oh spend the
bottle the good old days yeah 7 Minutes
in such a great encouraging game luckily
we had a super romantic song from our
youth to set the mood this is the part
where you're supposed to stick your my
mouth no that's direct let's do it
according to my watch you have 382 of
them how do you do that what add so fast
and you also talk like a grownup don't
worry I'm not nearly as smart as I think
I am is that that actress's actual voice
sounds like stum but younger we didn't
do anything could you still tell people
we kissed absolutely I think it is sure
Todd I actually didn't want to lie that
time although when people thought I
kissed someone they didn't really care
but when they thought that I slept with
someone hey Olive how's it going oh yeah
totally different place in the social
food chain n it didn't happen for
me nobody cared when I lost M people
were like him what took you so long you
guys know that I was here all weekend
right you were upstairs yeah you would
testify to that I would take a bullet
for you right between the eyes I would
slit my throat rather than say something
to someone that you didn't want me to
say we need a third example I like the
pants thank you they're Costco you can
have them when you get a little taller
if you want I'm never going to go
through puberty a I didn't until I was
14 nor did Olive why does that matter
I'm adopted what oh my God who told
you we were going to do this at the
right time listen to
me even when a man and a woman love each
other very much like your mother and I
used to
insid just don't cooperate with each
other honey why do you want us to take a
bullet if anyone asked if you were here
all weekend it's nothing just the rumor
mill what's the rumor mill turning out
these days hot Goss it's a little low on
grass oh clever word play I like it very
much you must be related to me only by
marriage give it to
me I want to be adopted by that Patricia
Stanley to I'm right here remember how I
told you Google Earth couldn't find me
if I was dressed up as a 10 story
building yeah you got to dress as
something more interesting it could find
me if I was dressed as a crack on a
sidewalk that's the beauty of being a
girl in high school people hear you had
sex once and Bam you're a bimbo I got to
admit I kind of liked being on the map I
know I like attention in any form
clearly Nathaniel Hawthorne is a complex
writer I read him originally when I was
five but I struggled tell me to break it
down for you is she attracted at Thomas
Hayden Church I think ironically we were
studying The Scarlet Letter isn't that
always the way the books you read in
class always seem to have some strong
connection with whatever angsty
adolescent drama is going on you're
Hester prin for those of you who haven't
read The Scarlet Letter here's all you
need to know this girl named Hester prin
has an affair with the minister is be
smirched and made to wear a red a for
adulterer H the town realizes she was
too harshly judged and she's really a
good person and she dies a saint rent
the movie but make sure it's the
original not the Demi Moore version
that's sounds fun wow to say that one
was freely adapted as a bit of an
understatement
G that's right she is so natural yeah
it's crazy she has it I think Hester
prin was a skank so you don't think she
was a victim at all she brought it on
herself perhaps you should embroider a
red a on your wardrobe you abominable
[__] wow you should get a wardrobe you
abominable whoa whoa not my best line
but it was provocative enough to L in
the principal's office I mean she just
fornicated that she didn't adulterate
yeah it's true guy wasn't married per
her account I just hope for your sake
you at least had the good sense to use
protection why your parents didn't
you're going to hell just as long as you
won't be there I can assure you I
won't you got enough staples in that
document there you ladies are tense you
need to get
laid
whoa hello handsome hey buddy this is
the first time I've have done anything
remotely misbehavior this is
foul coming from you that means a lot
you use a word like this again in my
school be your last you understand yes
sir I mean this isn't one of those
Progressive schools where the teachers
are called by their first names I hate
that this is school if I can keep the
girls off the pole and the boys off the
pipe I get a bonus woe wow preach man
now am I making myself clear yes sir
don't be a stripper even though it was
my [__] Alter Ego that said a bad word
in school it was my ass that got in
trouble what's your alter Go's name this
does kind of feel like an 80s comedy at
the same time too those ' 80s High
School
comedies oh my God the illusion is
shattered this exactly where they put
you in the gas chamber if you take your
head off at Disney World actually I
think they just uh they fire you you're
thinking of Disneyland Disney World is
much more liberal they put you in Disney
prison are you going to Melody btics
party I hadn't planned on it me neither
they're very liberal the guy went naked
It's a small world did you hear about
that no was he allow was he allowed to
do it yeah did they tolerate
it they were like you know what who need
to judge I think I'm in love with you
okay please tell me you at least left a
mark on that little scrunched up face of
hers it's not drew it wasn't the left
hand it was the right one I was pegged
you for a southpaw southpaw
it didn't happen oh yeah right her
Secret Save with me you little sex
monkey
[Music]
jeez which one in the dynamic are we I
am definitely the blonde girl it's
pretty obvious right yeah what did you
say let's just say it was an
inappropriate word well what did it
start with T oh t t yes let's go it's
better in the British accent I'll die on
that Hill I don't like in the American
accent with the tww
word it's an improv game noun adjective
a verb noun it's definitely slang think
British tally
Wacker Telly tube spell it with your PE
oh yeah spell it with your PE all right
so does this have anything to do with
the rumor that you mentioned the other
night I I love how sophisticated they
are with their language what's that twt
that's an a honey oh and I bet that girl
was acting like exactly what you called
her you have no idea always so
supportive there's got to be some type
of weird drama in this family that we
don't know about yeah their Dynamic is
heightened but I where are you from
originally where are you from
originally like they're not quite real
but I buy it somehow the openness and
acceptance I really just love it quk
this is so fun and Dynamic is so loose
together and fun yeah why are you here
judging from the amount of blood I saw
gushing out of your nose I thought you
were the bullied you think but principal
Gibbons is a homophobe which is why I
called him a fascist hey so what's with
your new look very cure bars I also
heard he was twice your age oh no no no
no he was a freshman in
college he's not
real what guy I slept with I made him up
wait you started the rumor indirectly I
guess sort of cutting back Bo is so
disor he's cleaning over there he's
cleaning over there that's really messed
up well you're not even a real [__] you
just want people to think you are it's
pathetic you could probably learn
something from me Brando are you saying
that that I should act straight so
people will like me oh golly guys I was
just suggesting that maybe these kids we
call peers are on to something you know
like like Maryann Bryant Maybe that
whole stuck up Jesus freak thing is an
act I need to see my gay friends more
often they have the sagest advice
there's just that back and forth you get
with a gay guy you don't really get with
yeah hetero friend it's like a whole
other reality you step into you're being
pretty cavaliere about this aren't you
supposed to be like eternally in love
with them and [__] yes yes I believe so
if I was a Gossip Girl in a Sweet Valley
with Traveling Pants but uh no I'm
not such a mish mash of titles there the
dialogue in the script is so how much to
carry yeah I was just talking about you
with my friend Rihanna you know Rihanna
she's uh perpetually angry she curses
like a SMY
sailor
y b what is B bedazzling personality big
that's my
identifier yes great identif yes wants
to talk to me about something yeah
probably wants to borrow an outfit
whatever big
tits
big it's really pre the editing but
there's a weird snappiness there yeah
the next day things took a turn for the
scandalous which brings us to part three
a lady's choice and a gentleman's
agreement who I I don't remember what
the writing credits were I'm trying to
figure out whose voice is in here it's
like there are ways in which
interactions are very like I know a bomb
back yeah definitely is there an Olive
here there's a whole jar of them in the
fridge sorry I must have the wrong
address just kidding come on any friend
of Olives it's a friend of our
daughters
just took me a
minute oh happy day Mama Oh I thought I
was going to have to spend my di on Boo
and pills to numb the loneliness is a
whole family of theater kids Olive has a
boy in her room a boy a boy wow a boy a
boy a boy a what now I will never be a
dad like them oh you will I mean like do
you want to be my girlfriend oh wow
they're taking the lies to a whole new
level yeah you said I should pretend to
be straight so yeah I didn't mean with
me you're not really uh my type yeah
you're not really my type either yeah I
know that I got that V where you'd
rather see a PE you know that I didn't
really have sex with a college guy right
I just told everybody I did so you're
saying I shouldn't really have sex I
should just say I had sex with someone
problem solved be do it in my whole life
man make a quite a living out get
yourself a ring people think you're like
people think you've done a lot of stuff
it's amazing you just act like you're
supposed to be there we could help each
other out you are on crack it doesn't
have to be a bonk it could be anything
it could be an imaginary butter bean
lemon squeeze cowbell I don't know what
any of that means well that's because
you're a virgin do you learn a whole new
type of vernacular when you your v card
on the back has a gloss of
terms these are how you refer to acts
now and and parts and people I'm being
suffocated and sure we can sit and
fantasize all we want about how things
are going to be different one day but
this is today and it sucked poor guy
dude please just help me cuz I can't
take another day of this I don't know
what I'll do just agree to it we need
the move it happened pinky promise I
don't do anything half F we're going to
do it in front of the whole school we're
going to tape it we're going to put it
online all right you have to do
everything I say and tell everyone that
I am Sensational we're going to need to
practice on something yeah yeah the next
night was the party at Melody bostic's
house she is the most popular girl in
school her parents let her have these
huge parties every time she catches them
doing it in the pool yeah I borrowed a
dress from my mom Brandon borrowed a
jacket from me and we put on a little
show nice hell yeah Brandon what's up I
hope you don't mind but we had a few
pre- cocktail party
cocktails we just came from the super
bad
party here's the S Mel B Brandon was
just in the middle of telling me this
really there like a room where you could
go where you could finish telling me
that thing that's
[Laughter]
funny just like her face during those
moments is that Olive with Brandon I
know what the hell
right we lived in a post love Simon
Universe when this was made none of this
would be
happening sneak out the window whoa
let's go realism what are you doing
relax Jesus what is with you days are
you are you really that repulsed by Lady
Parts what do you think I have down
there a
gnome that' be
fun what old house has this Keyhole you
can look through I accept it sure no
grunt grunt and make it
convincing just
[Music]
grunt there it
is oh yeah oh
yeah oh
yeah
[Music]
yeah commit commit to the bit like that
little
better I like you can just pretend she's
a guy from that
angle no no no take you from the back
yeah that's not going to make people
think
TR who Jesus Christ you smell that you
you smell that oh did he just see it
smelled it supposed to smell I don't
know but if it does you're not supposed
to comment on
it ready for the grand finale yeah
what I she thinks she sounds real yeah I
know she's like do it more like
I know what I'm talking about go forth
my son you're a man now SE life is a lie
you got to mess your hair up more
guys here what is this
evidence smell this
guy everyone look it's the smile I was
talking about hey who wants a sample who
wants a deeply problematic
[Music]
sample yeah
yeah oh my man's is accepted now and the
movie can end here and it will have all
been worth it BR hey Todd hi uh what are
you doing here I thought you were your
cousin's rehearsal dinner it was a quick
rehearsal I only had one line I do
you're way too old for high school man
you're like noticeably old yeah I'm here
can I get you a beer that rhymed he's
also seems so cool for Mr mascot boy
yeah he surprisingly Charming handsome
the full package really I always thought
pretending to lose my virginity would be
a little more um I don't know
special Judy Bloom should have prepared
me for that why are you documenting all
this just like a video Journal yeah who
is it too he seemed a little incredibly
gay I just want you to know your father
and I are totally supportive we love you
no matter what the sexual orientation of
your opposite sex sex
partner I dated a homosexual tell me you
did not marry and have children with him
no Stanley Tucci's not actually gay your
father is as straight as they come a
little too straight if you know what I
mean girlfriend he's a homophone can you
shut the door
please okay door's right over there keep
going that is actually one of the
funnier versions of the quirky sexually
free parent who says too much yeah
normally that the jokes are so just like
straightforward vulgar well they're
playing her like that's just their
characters not like this is hilarious
comedy jokes we're writing howy we are
is it true you got withand at Melody
[__] part yo BT calm down yeah just
because you lost your virginity doesn't
mean you can go around throwing your cat
at everybody I'm not throwing my cat at
everybody what does that mean uh maybe
there's a cat they haven't established
yet on screen but she she gave it to
somebody best friend's duty to let her
know that everyone and I do mean
everyone is calling her a dirty skank
jeez
man and you're a jealous virgin dang
people thought I was a dirty steap fine
I will become the dirtiest thing they
ever seen wow she is becoming the lie
it's was going to end in just a crazy
orgy oh yeah just like the original book
version of
it the only way to get back to our nons
[__] reality sounds like you're having
sex in here which I know can't be true
due to the fact that you have have a
homosexual boyfriend he's not my
boyfriend no judgment All God's Children
I was gay once we all do it it's
okay
beautiful I don't know what reality they
belong to but okay once we all do we all
do
it this is I can see how the creators of
Corella saw this and we're like this is
her right here yep this put Disney
the a the a someone was listening in
class it's weird I've seen Cruella and
now I see the similarities of between my
name is an anagram for I love what's a
what's an anagram look at that big boy
jeez we are officially over oh rats hey
I want my juicy sweater back was way too
loser running chest anyway ouch man
those juicy track suits were like
everything at this time everybody had
one I think it's really cool to see a a
high school female character who's
actually like really really intelligent
and articulate has a wide range of
vocabulary you know it's really cool to
see and it feels natural we need to pray
for her amen we also need to get her the
hell out of here
amen I was there I heard the whole thing
that's not something you need to
advertise Kurt sorry but I was who's
that guy next to Amanda bindes cam gig
gig gnet he's been in stuff he was in a
t I think yes yes make God a promise
that we will remain pure and chased
until marriage we promise we promise sad
part is I've definitely known a lot of
people like her oh
[Music]
yeah that's a great song uh Brandon told
me what you did for rest assured it was
equally a th for me he told me the truth
I was just hoping that maybe you could
do the same for me no yes I am about 6
seconds away from flapping you so hard
your teeth will bleed can you do it in
front of everyone I don't need your
permission you know what the hell did
you just say man are you threatening me
I'll give you a 100 bucks you are
repugnant uh duve that's the problem a I
would not look at you look at me no I
mean not after a crack like that not
after the whole like I could just do it
anyway I want a $100 gift card deposited
into my locker by noon
tomorrow are you in whatever get out of
hand deal then a thanks Olive this is
getting dark she's a she's a uh it's an
ad friendly way to say rumor I was
soliciting sex for money spread around
the school faster than well faster than
the first rumor about me spread sure and
it's interesting too how like obviously
this is like a real messy sexual
situation but she still has that like
Assurance and that like confidence in
that way yeah like effortlessly and
that's part of her like intellect and
her whip crack like she's just like a
she feels fully kind of
realized man the way they shot the the
montages and transitions is wild yeah
spread like wildfire but for people who
knew the truth I was open for business
and whether I liked it or not I had a
lot of customers joang back there Phil
Lord gave me 100 bucks so he could tell
people we hooked up behind the library
what did Chris Miller give you Chris
Miller gave me $40 worth of movie passes
for my pretend cowbell Phil lorda Chris
Miller yay are they involved they must
be that's crazy do they write this but
even that is better than sanj Chandra
sear seriously that's the guy from
Broken Lizard or whatever 20% off to
Bath and Body Works is that how much our
imagin trist meant to you it's all I can
afford how's that my problem
Amigo I want John qac holding a boom box
outside my window I want Jud Nelson
thrusting his fist into the air cuz he
knows he got me just once yeah I want my
life to be like an 80s movie preferably
one with a really awesome musical number
are we going to get a musical number in
this movie definitely this brings us to
part four how I Olive Pendergast went
from assumed trup to an actual home
recer oh go oh no yeah I think you're
taking your reading assignment a little
bit too seriously well I was really
hoping to get an A
[Music]
does I don't know what your generation's
fascination is with documenting your
every thought but I can assure you
they're not all
diamonds such a beautiful delivery if I
read one more paper from one of your
classmates who talks about how hot she
is in the bathtub her fake British
accent or is she still married to Ashton
coocher I'm going to kill myself coocher
coer stay golden Stay Gold Pony Boy hi
it's R she in this he Avengers D is for
delightful see
you yeah right here in front of the
window oh wait is that that's not the
girl everyone's talking about is it it
is you know that snotty Jesus Freak
office I have has been bitching about
her oh this is a public school
baby making spaghetti with meat enjoy
eating your meat and balls enjoy eating
your balls enjoy both of them dude
everyone is perfectly cast yeah I'm a
little questioned about pen
bading so more only part of this movie
hean and her best friend both seem like
a little bit more older and Polished
than everybody else but like I still
like them both fire open up to you do
you promise this stays in confidence
yeah see I'm the guidance counselor
that's what I
do I mean I have a reputation to uphold
don't you then know all about it already
don't tell anyone I'm doing this please
oh boy I really don't need those oh you
really do Olive do what you got to do
okay let your freak flag fly just make
sure you have
an yeah fist full fist full of rubbers r
was he having impure thoughts yeah it
must have been maybe he's also gay every
guy at the school is gay why was he
blubbering like a baby is he struggling
with his sexuality know you insenstive
rhymes with which his parents are going
through a divorce oh the ultimate sin
yeah they're going to hell now but you
should still honor them pursuant to the
fourth Commandment sometimes our
boyfriend's parents they get divorced
she such a a love the sound
how long uh do these Embraces usually
last cuz I got to go but are you going
to be okay yes I'm going to be okay hug
it out wait why are you even being so
nice to me I didn't I got through in
you can we please be friends
absolutely oh my goodness she's going to
start some [__] rumor huh I guess
she's still accepting you in your
wardrobe and all that stuff m is in the
hospital he is in so much pain the nurse
didn't know what was
[Music]
wrong oh my
god well it's just what I thought chamia
uhoh tell me now or I'm going to kill
you right here ol ol Pendergast oh dude
oh Jesus no pendas no I have to call you
back okay oh that's
cruel [__] oh that rhymes with
which
hey yeah but what was I supposed to say
you and then my mom tells MaryAnn's mom
dude I love you and I want to be with
you and nobody can stop us not my mother
not Maryanne not even the school board
or the president of the
Americas America that is shocking that
yeah I did not I would not have
anticipated that in a thousand years wow
they totally switch both blue you think
Thomas Hayden Church is the one yeah
they were in the same shade of blue
these two her and him I'm so sorry Olive
I'm sorry but I I I messed up oh you
know you should know that my marriage is
not great okay we haven't slept together
in like in months in months all right so
finally this great looking guy comes oh
yeah why are you pouring everything out
and then he finds out that he has chamia
so then he's telling everybody that it
was you so he has to say cuz he didn't
want me to lose my job and he doesn't
want to get in trouble either so wow but
I I'm going to fix it I'm going to tell
everyone that it's me okay I'll just
I'll lose my job will she take it on
she's going to take on the LIE better
pay pay me a lot of money for this I
want a $100 gift
card any local establishment will
do I could have clenia oh my my God the
whole world knows I've been around no
you haven't no you haven't cuz a real
can't admit it to herself much less
others ouch it's a story is about it is
it's an
[Laughter]
aljor so I guess I shouldn't be too
shocked that these people wanted my
diseased ass out of there Jezebel why
are you doing this I'm trying to make
the school a better place can we just
start a petition to get rid of all the
lead paint thank you for helping with
the budget you okay I'm awesome I'm
awesome screw all these people all of
you haven't you heard I already did I
have a she gave that smokey eye just
there do you have a religion section
it's right over there can I help you
with something the Bible oh that's in
best sellers right next to
Twilight yep as it should be 600 pages
singles based and as every war that's
ever been fought can tell you there are
many ways you can interpret it except
the Civil War that was pure racism sure
I've been pretending to be what is the
Catholic way of phrasing this a
harlot she a lot of people have been
asking me to do things and I thought it
was okay because it wasn't real huh a
lot of people hate me now it's real also
I've never had this good of lighting in
any confessional ever as any movie
always does aren't you supposed to say
something want me to say 10 Hill Mar's
pay a fine Advanced token to nearest
railroad
hello yeah they're not just there all
the
time think of that what would be worse
lying or adultery or is lying about
adultery just like double whammy sorry
come on come on oh Jesu christe I had
unwittingly sought advice from the
father of the leader of my Lynch M no
le okay I've narrowed it down to the
other Bolin girl or The Bucket
List jeez it's the bucket list this is
it this is the greatest decision I'm so
happy with this decision I want to have
a decision-making process like that buck
aist is are rated yeah a progressive
family how you've been dressing the last
few days no judgment but you kind of
look like a stripper mom a high-end
stripper for Governors or athletes
yep you're kind of starting to worry us
a little should we be kind of worried I
don't think so I got it all under
control okay okay then let's bucket list
this [__] I love that family especially
the adopted kid he's a real character he
is a real cut up that kid I still
actually hadn't been asked out on a real
date starting to think I actually did
have a gnome down there until finally
hey Olive you need a no Mech to me maybe
want to go out or something I was
thinking about getting a hot air balloon
you know bringing along some champagne
and then uh possibly reading some Sylvia
pla this is a big prank they're playing
just go to the Lobster Shack cuz it's
you know a little easier I love the
Lobster Shack this is going to become
Carrie cool all right well cool I don't
know I think I've seen this guy play
Charming before maybe they're messing
with us how much times lost of this
movie yeah where's pen
bansley you're a real gentleman nah just
a guy having dinner with a girl girl
asking her to eat with him Medical
Science really has not substantiated
claims that any particular food
increases sexual desire or performance
but guys just spend and spend to ply
women with food they think it's going to
get them
lucky you know that some people actually
eat grind up raser horn because it's s
to increase the size of the male sex
organ that's not true at all oh no am I
talking too much no no no you just
burning through a lot of topics really
fast hope you're happy happy birthday's
been the best wood Todd work here this
piece of cake is free happy happy
birthday the best you're the
best he's an aphrodesiac he's got one
right on top of his
head Happ yum I just remembered I am so
allergic to shellfish oh dude I have a
gift certificate keep the tip thank
thank you I'm sorry I'm sorry but we
have to go
come on come on come on just goes oh no
you already got it no no no no
no this is a horror movie yes this is my
nightmare $200 to the Home Depot you
knew this was coming Pete so what do we
do on this date whatever 200 bucks gets
me sheeps ew I'm not really having sex
with people for money I'm saying I'm
having sex with people for money but I'm
not having sex with people for
money damn no stop come on just
relax
oh come on this is
[__] nah that that truth needed to
come out boy oh for the sake of your
friend hey
Olive
Tod I don't think he's real I think he's
in a something something of Her
Imagination yeah she's hallucina yeah
let me drive you home
I've got four different cars to choose
from yes take your pick you want to talk
about it what's just say everybody
thinks I'm a for the first time I'm
starting to believe it what no once upon
a time there was a scared little kid at
a party in a in a dark room who was not
ready for his first kiss and you there
was this uh amazing girl who lied for
him I can't believe I remember that a
why wouldn't you remember that told big
moment times I pretend you were my first
real kiss you yeah it's a vulnerable
emotional moment you know who was it was
Ranna yeah it was uh I think it was like
a a year after that or something it
sucked by the way wow God she knew how I
felt about you wait how do you feel
about oh and here I am feeling so bad
that that's just perfect wait wait hold
on hold a second how uh how do you feel
about it oh no no no no no no no I have
felt cuz I thought I feel no it's f
playing it cool yeah in second grade
what do you like a Sant for people's
addresses just for people who I think
are cool you think I'm cool I do and I
think you're pretty I'm also a bartender
yep why did that rumor spread I like to
keep my business to myself the business
I'm a CEO of to be clear if I promise
not to tell anyone can I kiss you right
now I don't want to kiss you with
mascara running down my face I've wanted
to kiss you since 8th grade I need to
get my b business in order before I drag
you into it what if I told you I want to
be dragged into it I want in on this
action I got $300 to Arby's
for full
partner I'll Scout him if you get the
gift cards it's a really fascinating
story no idea what this mov about and
it's a great Twist on the it's not just
doing the book it's like twisting it the
lies had to stop and I knew there was
only one person I could count on to set
the story straight brand did you hear
that Brandon ran away from home he left
his parents a note that said I'm gay
[__] and then he skipped down with
some big huling black guy oh he did it
he did I went to everyone I'd helped and
begged them to say it wasn't true I gave
you money you gave me a gift card to
AutoZone I don't even have a car yep my
guilt stems for my indiscretion and
yours for lying I could just tell
everyone the truth and get you fired and
put in jail he is of age okay it's
perfectly legal in the state of
California I checked perfectly why why
don't you ask yourself if you were an
adult who would you believe huh who
would you believe who would you believe
oh golly thou do protest too much Mrs
Griffith was pure evil but I still
shouldn't have done what I did your wife
has chyia and she's sleeping with a
student and she gave it to him and she's
trying to blame me there's the home
wreck what I'm sorry
oh golly Mr Griffith if you ever see
this just know that I was I was wrong oh
this is how she's getting trueth out
there it's going on Facebook it's a
video essay or Myspace
yes it's going on Friendster I ended a
marriage looking back that's the thing I
regret the most yeah transcends your
it's
okay he cheated on his uh fiance a lot
in uh sideways sideways oh yeah he he
deserves it I had a similar situation
when I was your I had a horrible
reputation and people said awful things
about me I SLE with a whole bunch of
people a sww a heap of Tech mostly guys
mom you're wonderful and you'll handle
this the same way I did with an
incontrovertible sense of humor true
that you're much smarter than I am so
you'll come out of this much better than
I
did thank you they're great together I
know so it was time to put an end to all
this once and for all by telling my side
of the story interesting to have this
location with her best friend and then
now have it with her mom at night part
five not with the fizzle but with a bang
cuz of all those people you didn't bang
I had one outfit left and I figured
about 30 seconds to do it plus I really
wanted my own awesome musical number oh
yeah she's getting it let's go let's go
let's go
[Music]
I
hey it's funny she's in a wood
[Music]
[Applause]
pile hey the Blue Devil is
[Music]
back she going to tell the truth
yeah knock on
wood she got the best looking guy in the
whole school yep that's how you do it
for the main event log on to
www.free.com tonight at 6 p.m. and I
know it interferes with the basketball
game but come on would you rather be
here cheering on the woodchucks or
watching watch me do one what on Earth
here you all are listening to me pretend
to have sex with Brandon paying me to
lie for you and calling me every name in
the book you know what it was just like
Hester that's the one thing the movies
don't tell you how shitty it feels to be
an outcast yeah warranted or
[Music]
not perfect update I uh I I borrowed my
neighbor's mower I came right over that
almost rhymed I know I spent a minute on
it wow hey he's done it all my man
that's Todd I really like this guy I
might even lose my virginity to him I
don't know when it'll happen but it is
nobody's goddamn business true that but
your own you'd be a terrible
[Music]
influencer
no
you've earned it
[Music]
kids
excelsor let's blow this Popsicle
stand hey the wacky credits are back I
like
it whoa I want to see who made
it dad's name was Dill
my wife's name's Olivia which means
Olive Branch oh snap look out
now which would explain why I'm so
freaking attracted to Ms Stone yeah this
makes sense it all make yeah it's all
clicking together man she dictated your
whole life
path Yolanda
snowball
really those
guy they really used ohigh to to the
fullest got this is a really cool way to
do the end credits as an end credits
person yeah man going with John's family
to see movies growing up like I'm ready
to n
that last Fade Out it's we got to get
out of here n man just chill just chill
appreciate before Marvel before Marvel
made people begrudgingly tolerate not
paying attention to the credits until a
scene pops up oh my God they waved at us
did you see that
dude I think it was Sea Biscuit I think
Sea Biscuit was my first time with you
guys oh that's the movie they jump in
with man woo I was like gosh we're we're
not
leaving sorry still mad at your family
about it and now you do it ironically
whenever we go to the theaters out of
spite for me Totally Miss who wrote the
movie and there's no other way to find
out years of doing YouTube and still
don't know how to find out who wrote
movie someone's going to come up with
like a database someday that'll have
every movie in it there's going to be
something at the end of this
road oh they're going to slowly enter
the gates of hell yes cuz hell is
between here and the Orient as
established earlier hello there esteemed
viewer of the real rejects I Greg Alba
language connoisseur and worldly
gentleman I'm here to bestow upon you
the secrets of Babel the language app
that transforms mere mortals into
linguistic gods in just 3 weeks why
Babel you inquire my dear friends in
this age of monolingual mundanity
mundanity mundanity mundanity Babel is
are Beacon of Hope crafted by an army of
over 150 language experts their lessons
are like linguistic caviar Rich refined
and oh so satisfying personal Tale
Triumph I once whispered sweet nothings
in Spanish or for the lame in espanol to
my wife courtesy of Babel her reaction
well I'll tell you she was utterly
Bewitched Greg you silver tongue devil
no paraphrase she exclaimed such
vocabulary as I bass in the glory of my
perfect pronunciation is Babel isn't
just about learning words it's about
embracing the art of conversation with
podcasts live classes and a veritable
smorgus sport of interactive
lessons I know the words I'm saying and
their speech recognition it's like
having a personal language Butler
ensuring every syllable is impeccably
Cris that breaks your Sals for an offer
of monumental proportions here's a
special limited time deal for our
viewers and listeners to get you started
right now get 55% off your Babel
subscription but again only for our
viewers at babel.com
rejects 55% off at babel.com
rejects spelled b a
bb.com rejects rules and restrictions
May apply join me the Greg Albin the
adventure of language Mastery at Babel
we shall not just learn no nay we shall
conquer the world of of communication or
as they say in
Spanish we're done with this ad all
righty time to get a little bit serious
so around the holiday season we often
focus on getting gifts for others but
it's also important to consider the
gifts that we give to ourselves
personally I found that maintaining
mental health balance is a continuous
Journey cuz like I mentioned before I've
been diagnosed with type 2 bipolar ADHD
and PTSD and in a lot of ways I've also
grown up in the last few years on camera
with you guys and therapy has been a
crucial part of my life before Channel
even and like many of you my anxiety and
depression seems to magnify this time of
year still don't quite understand the
winter Blues but it does however therapy
does help me navigate the ups and downs
and stay grounded for the most part and
while I have my own approach to therapy
I understand everyone's path is unique
and that's why we are proud to be
sponsored by better help this week it's
an online platform that makes therapy
accessible and tailored to your needs
and I know a few people who have
discovered therapy via better help and
it has been transformative you start
with a questionnaire that helps match
you with a licensed therapist and the
best part and an important part you can
switch therapist anytime ensuring the
right fit for you better help is all
about convenience and flexibility it
fits into your schedule and it's all
online so whether you're looking to
start therapy for the first time or
continue your journey better help can be
a great option so in the season of
giving remember to give yourself what
you need too with better help take that
step towards your better self so you can
visit betterhelp.com sreal rejects for
10% off your first month that's better
hp.com rejects take care and stay
healthy reject Nation happy holidays
Bert V Royal wrote this movie we all
know Bert V Royal berv Royal he wrote
Big Hero 6 which you can definitely see
kind of he was additional crew on Big
Hero 6 it's Lac
yeah turn a lot of TV yeah Will Gluck
yeah I was going to say what where else
have I heard his name oh he did Friends
with Benefits that was a great movie and
Peter Rabbit everyone love and the Annie
with uh Jamie Fox John oh yeah John
what's up dude did it did it live up as
someone who is a fanatic yes Over The
Scarlet Letter did it uh live up to the
hype yeah this is pretty much a one
toone adaptation you know yeah and uh
I'm really pleased with how literary it
was you know keeping all of the original
uh you know dialogue from the book and
all those recognizable ohigh locations
that Nathaniel Hawthorne was writing
about at the time I like that they
really just went there instead of doing
it on a volume or or you know CGI
against green screens or whatever uh and
I think this is like if you ever have
like she says in the movie like watch
the original movie and not the Demi
Moore one I think you could just watch
EAS if you ever have to do a book report
oh Scarlet Letter and then you know
you'll know everything you need to know
so uh yeah I think this was perfect
actually enough with the sardan sardonic
quips sardonic cast uh no had a great
time with it this was cool I mean you
know obviously uh there are a lot of man
voices authoring this movie uh but I I
really like well that's what made it
accessible for a man to watch that's why
we enjoyed
it like this is how women should be
interpreted yes yes if if if Tina Fay
had written this count me out but be
like this is not at all now you're just
preaching messages what I can't
understand what anyone is saying um no
like I I really enjoyed the way this
came together and I like like uh this
Rony sex comedies can go either way for
me like I I can easily enjoy one but
it's not like my go-to genre necessarily
and I like that this is a sex comedy
about the concept rather than the actual
thing which is the actual act uh which I
think is part of what gives it such a
lovely Edge and and gives it the
opportunity to inhabit so many layers
and nuances and stuff because it's like
Breezy and fun in so many ways and it's
like the perfect concept but I think
it's also a lovely Twist on the story
the book because that's a lot more
straightforward and this is yeah like it
starts out as a fun kind of prospect
that then goes wrong and spirals way out
of control and I think it's a great
blend of when they take a piece of
literature as they have with many movie
you know like I think she's the man is
another one of those and clueless is one
of those and and there are a lot of
movies that borrow directly from like
Jane Austin or Shakespeare or whatever
um and are kind of doing it but just
Harry Potter yeah Harry Potter
definitely they borrow from the Harry
Potter books yeah Zack Snider's Rebel
Moon same thing it was going to be uh I
liked that this instead of just
interpreting The Source material instead
of interpreting a source material and
making it modern and using like just the
straight building blocks of that this
took a clear Touchstone in The Scarlet
Letter and played into it but played off
of it as well in a way that I think not
to slight any of those other movies cuz
I love some of those movies but I I like
that this did prison Ras prison of asan
totally is is um y old Goodman
Brown some old short story I read Once
Upon a Time uh I yeah I like that this
did that and then went the extra step of
and you have all the 80s movies
influences in there too so yeah it does
a riff on the thing but without
only doing that thematically it built on
and and went a bunch of different
directions from and I think that's that
makes helps to make it kind of rich and
nice MH and having it posed through her
perspective and following yeah this sort
of meta sex comedy journey of of again
the idea much more so than the actual
act I don't know like it it could be
runer obviously it's not an R-rated
comedy but like this is the kind of
flavor I very much kind of lock into and
gravitate toward when it comes to a
movie like this because there is a fair
amount of runchy subject matter and
whatnot but it also has like a wholesome
heart at the core that feels very clear
and not like it's tacked into the movie
or like it's working in spite of how
crude or whatever it wants to be like I
thought it was really well-tempered
what did you think
sir uh yeah I think
that we could have used some like nudity
with them M yeah man it's called easy
yeah easy a for easy ass shots
yeah and I got to say um as a as a
viewer disappointed didn't believe any
of it as a pretentious film snob was
really impressed
yes yeah yeah yeah especially the
restraint to not show the easy ass shots
were scho character she wasn't in high
school when it was made right she's
going to be none of these actors are
dropped out of Sucker Punch to do this
movie did she really cor s be fact right
there I would say that worked out so say
that that I wonder if jenim Malone then
from Saved which is a similar but not
quite the same comedy stepped into
Sucker Punch there you go perfect I
haven't seen Sucker Punch nor have I I
can imagine that this probably exercises
her acting talents better than
everything I've ever heard about Sucker
Punch man in Sucker Punch she's going to
have to have had
to shots I was looking
for in the shortest possible she said
that thing about her skirt never going
above her fingers and you know like not
the case it's Sucker Punch man yeah yeah
yeah I mean i' I've always heard good
things about this movie and that it was
a surprisingly good film and this was
this came out at the time when um what
2010 yeah yeah because we used to get
like a bunch of runchy R-rated comedies
like the boom of appow films sure and
that sort of changed comedy as we know
it like the will Ferell which which had
a lot of appal produced but eventually
he wasn't producing every will Ferell
movie but the will Ferell is yeah is a
much more farcical heightened thing and
then app was yeah you had the and then
appat was like let them improvise and
we'll make a movie you know let's make
it realer yeah I'm always happier when I
see something you know like there's that
joke I can't find anything about like
the fill or might have just been
coincidence honestly uh about Phil Lord
and Chris Miller and what I love about
this kind of Comedy is the sharpness and
how it's like made made like an actual
film it's really composed you kind of
get the sense of like this goty like an
action director or something because
there's so much style to it and there's
substance behind the film making you
know energy yeah that everything seems
very purposeful and thought out prior to
shooting instead of let's just hire
funny people let them be funny and then
we'll make a movie out of it and then
we'll do some basic coverage and yeah
yeah I mean they thematically thought
everything like as a script it all
starts with a script right and as a
script I think it's a very very solid
screenplay this movie is only 90 minutes
long and the characters are so well
thought out I mean em Emma Stone is uh
overhyped you know she can't act every
time I Ser something I'm like gosh can't
stand this
[__] her no she's uh she's she's an
icon she's like great and everything and
she just seems like like I can't think
of another actor who who who I would say
another actress especially who I would
say is like it just seems so natural
like that when people say like Girl Next
Door relatable or or just doesn't sound
like they're reading from a script
whatever like she's given and especially
in a movie like this where she's given
these lines of dialogue where even
sometimes I'm like wait what was that
word me you I'm like I'm some of the
characters in this movie going uh yeah I
mean not my head because there's a
camera point at me and I'll laugh but
sometimes I'm also going I'm not I'm not
sure I know what that means but I think
I understand you know you're laughing
with the energy and then thinking back
to the actual content of the words yeah
yeah and I I love the representation of
that kind of character uh in this film
because you know you normally wouldn't
see that a lot of times that level of
wit and that wide range of this this
crazy vernacular you would not really
see it in a way that just is a part of
the character that doesn't draw a draw
an obnoxious amount of attention to it
like it's just the way she talks you
know and then sometimes there'll be
scenes where people will be like what
does that mean and I think that's
appropriate but more often than not
they're not just um and it's not like
she's the odd one in the family too
who's like
commit to the bit family I mean you
could see the way with the way her
parents are are uh are drawn in this
movie of why she is the way she is and I
like how it was formed in a supportive
loving Manner and even though she is an
outcast and the odd one
out and it does not really blend in with
the crowd like she's the furthest thing
from a cliche high school girl and and
she doesn't care to fit in with the
Norm yet none of that I feel like in a
typical movie like you might have like
one wacky parent or something like that
and you really I think they go against
the grain here on how she is formed the
way she is because her parents are also
kind of odd they got strange
idiosyncrasies but like just just
above they're they're weird they they
are weird but in a way that feels like
believable for the world that's
constructed here yeah and they're also
very accepting and they they also have a
lot of intelligence and sophistication
as well that comes out in the way they
speak vocabulary is a big part of their
household when they are just conversing
with each
other and I I love that they had that
they had that done in a way that were
most movies I think there would have
been a bit of a she's liked the way she
is because she is like liberal
rebellious girl or some [__] I don't
know so I'm making up like the terrible
version that you would more than like
right the obnoxious version of this yeah
yeah yeah and and I I think it this
movie just had a great heart about it
because even like all the stuff they
they found they managed to make like a
solid PG-13 sex comedy that
felt rier and vulgar more vulgar than it
actually is yeah um but they never show
you or do anything or ever go hard hard
are with their language whatsoever yeah
and there's like no strong language
and it's all rooted in this this woman
who's who just finds herself compelled
to do things out of the kindness of her
heart but then eventually things go dark
for her when it starts when she starts
acting on it for other reasons where she
is just like I want the gift cards I
want the money yeah but but when it is
just from the kindness of her heart you
know it's not as terrible for her yeah
it it nicely represents something that's
like a kind of wild but but tangible and
sort of sweet idea then sort of
spiraling out of control after a while
or yeah getting big enough to a point
that then there are too many branches of
it to you know contain and I thought
they yeah orchestrated not that it's uh
as harsh as like the contrast of a
boogie nice but it kind of has that
thing of like you know hey this is
starting out you know pretty good
opportunity for me to yeah increase my
social clout and also make a little
money
and then and then yeah [__] becomes too
real and I like the way they spread
things out too cuz there's that whole
bit where she's like you know this is
where I became a home wer and it's not
until a while later that that ties all
together and and yeah it's like it gives
you enough time to it plants seeds gives
you enough time to forget and and and
the movie just kind of lives in what
feels like a very natural pace after
that and I think it has a nice blend of
height versus Earnest and sincerity
because like especially in the dialogue
and no shade I I know some people get
very upset over stuff like Juno no shade
to I like Juno but that is an example of
a movie where it's like all the dialogue
is hyper stylized and this movie has
some of that and it's very apparent with
her family but I think it has just
enough of it but not enough that it
boils over into like this is a complete
you know sort of comic strip now or
something like they assign it to to the
right characters yeah there's the right
amount of Whimsy placed in the right
spots for the most part there were there
were very few if any like characters or
dynamics that didn't feel like they fit
even if they like the family to me is is
one of the broader parts or or toward
the broader end of the spectrum but like
their shared energy really just felt
like everyone playing off of each other
in the Moment Like and and they had such
lovely energy collectively that that
yeah like even if there were times where
I was like how did you get the most
perfect parents ever but at the same
time that's that's part of the charm I
thought they were used nicely and so
like yeah because there's no like they
never do a moon like here's my traumatic
flashback yeah yeah here's the thing we
don't talk about secretly the reason
we're secretly dysfunctional yeah here's
my wound you know yeah but her identity
still feels very specific totally as
opposed to rooting it in trauma which is
kind of weirdly refreshing well cuz it
Roots it in things that are more
tangible like the discomfort of yeah
being at a party with a bunch of kids
and and being kind of introduced to
ideas that obviously everyone's like
fascinated by but you don't quite
understand you're learning about you
know all all the birds and bees stuff
and uh and that whole thing with her
doing the kiss yeah them them making the
promise after to spin the bottle and and
the the uh kiss the lie about the kiss
uh like those are real things or those
are yeah these are things that aren't as
huge World rening Stakes like in adult
life but like yeah when you're in junior
high or you're in high school yeah these
things are important and they do affect
how your whole social interaction goes
well that's why I love the shots when
they're saying that the rumors spread
like wildfire they make it feel like a
city yeah you know and it's so while in
adult life you're dealing with the city
a lot of the time yeah sometimes just
like the office workplace or whatever um
every everywhere is a high school uh it
is it's true I think did you hear that
from Josh when we were younger that's
what I heard that from Josh told me that
when we were younger he said when you
grow up you realize every everywhere's a
high school and that that always stuck
with me yeah as a h school student
always stuck yeah you didn't miss as
much as you thought you did you go
anywhere with enough people yeah
everywhere's at high school that always
stuck with me when I heard that um and
and yeah but they do make it feel like a
little city uh at all times so it's not
really about cuz like you know you could
you can have it be about there's a
Skybeam happening and the world's going
to end but it doesn't make the stakes
feel any real or tangible yeah it's just
about uh selling the audience on the
importance and the significance of the
emotionality to the characters and and I
think this movie does a great job at
that you know with struggles that I
don't really know like you can EMP I can
empathize with a lot of bit with like
the guy who's dealing with uh being gay
in high school like I don't know what
that's like yeah and and and and what
the last time I get my updates of what
high school might be like from what I
hear people talk about in movies like 21
Jump Street was like the last high
school movie I've
seen maybe that maybe gay people aren't
as trst in in in uh
California you know I know I've been in
like many other parts of America for
sure but maybe in
like North Hollywood I feel like it's
more different now than even in 2010
like that's what I mean yeah I think
there I'm sure that people still
struggle I just don't know I don't know
I'm not going to act like I know I think
the world as we know it is pro it is
probably like a 21 drum Street thing
where like we live in a world where it's
safer than ever relatively speaking to
come out but I got to imagine that high
school is still a harsh place and people
are always making gay jokes anyway
especially at that age so like yeah it's
it's I feel like that will always be
until there's no you know friction in
society that'll always be a sort of
relevant thing yeah yeah well even with
her character and uh the the the sexual
pressures that that you exper I can
identify with that you know when like
you have friends around you who are
experiencing stuff and and going through
the emotions in life and and you're not
and you don't really understand your
identity or emotional Association when
it comes to these things and like how
how do I and some sometimes you get
older you still don't really understand
or know and it's a constant discover you
know like so I I I get that it uh I I
understand that aspect of it so there's
still things to relate on um so yeah
there's a lot of great things I love
about it but we talk about some things
that I thought were kind of on the a bit
of a dip oh I do think Penn Badgley
feels the most cliche out of any
character here there he's the only one
where I feel like there's nothing like
you are
exactly this guy in this genre of movie
yeah and we don't really get to know you
beyond the archetype and I could see a
defense for that's the point
because by the end he is the embodiment
of of the kind of fantasy boyfriend she
would want who's doing doing all the
amalgamation of 80s things at the end
but if you look at the characters that
Emma Stone is riffing on uh characters
Emma Stone is sighting of the kind of
guys they all have personalities that
are all distinct from each other yes so
I would go against that defense assuming
that is someone's defense for why pen
bash's character is severely
underwritten you know yeah yeah I I
enjoyed his presence most certainly but
I he's pen bad he's Charming
natur but but I I can't uh I can't
disagree I mean I don't find myself
longing for like a bunch of extra scenes
but at the same time yeah he is uh the
least fleshed and the least he gets the
least opportunity to like I don't know
kind of be a real person cuz I think
they're they do make some interesting
like the feels like a ghost yes he did
kind of I get what you mean or like an
imaginary yeah like a hallucination or
something just shows up to be like hey I
accept you yeah seen he my inner voice
telling me I have selfworth uh I yeah I
I think it's interesting too because
they they bothered to KN like it doesn't
get dark or traumatic in a lot of ways
but they do bother to Nuance certain
things like I I I appreciate that the
one guy the second guy who comes to her
was like uh Brandon told me what you did
like that guy
they play with in a way where by the end
it's kind of clear like no this guy kind
of sucks there's a lot of like uh
relatable and and kind of pitiable
things about him but at the ultimate end
of the day his attitude is a is a bad
one where it counts and you also get the
moment with the guy where they go to the
Lobster restaurant and everything and
that is like you know it gets close to
being a kind of harsh scenario it is
could have been much more harsh um and
so like even those small characters get
a bit of Flesh John I'm going to
interrupt you what is this thing that
keeps happening on the OBS we have an
OBS that's happened with Aaron and
Andrew when they were filming and there
like big thumbs up thing pops up just
keep this in the video [__] never seen
that in my life it just it keep it
completely puts our backup recording on
pause and I have no idea what the [__]
that is oh good I wonder like if there
is a way to like take a photo of it
and and explain to someone at Apple
support totally like hey this [__] just
keeps happening and it completely it
like I I have no idea why it pops up or
and see now it's completely Frozen oh
good um uh yeah it's a pain in the ass
question I don't know look into
that anyway what were you say well just
that those those more what is that did
it again we saw it in real time form
yeah I don't
know uh I have no idea what that Isen
it's like a thumbs up being like we're
here to free yeah great job your video
it's done no your thumbs up video's done
you did a good job I've never never had
a thumbs up actually be like a threat
yeah or at least a a dismaying like you
know crowbar thrown into the gears
wrench thrown here oh man it's annoying
let's try let's see if it does it again
it's not doing it now now hold let me
try this I'm maybe it's CU I open
this I don't know airpods are always
grabbing the computer some somehow yeah
I mean it's not now though see yeah I
don't I don't take on my airpods when
people are filming because of that [__]
that's a hazard yeah Apple's like
connect everything everything must
connect and it's going to happen
now yeah because it's I mean to be fair
you know it's all also like if you
wanted to just connect them
independently it would probably lead to
research of how to do it especially the
way they remix their controls any what
were we saying
about those small characters even get
like some weird little amount of Flesh
uh and and again I I very much enjoyed
pen Badgley but he oddly is maybe the
most sort of Fantasy
character you know in in that because
even the parents who again do border on
that have a lot of really lovely Earnest
heartfelt nuance and and like actual
kind of guiding spirit I I felt like
they didn't they mean for for a
character like Emma Stone especially who
is such
a a very specific type of
Personality uh like just very detailed
and and she she kind of goes for like
the most cliche guy well she goes to the
first guy who is just a good guy not a
not a trademark good guy but just like
an actual decent person it seems yeah
I'm like I didn't really get a sense of
like the how their friendship has
gestated over the years I just don't
really got a good sense of his
personality other than he's like a nice
guy well they ride most of the stuff
with him on that flashback so I feel
like yeah yeah that was my one one
concern and I think Amanda binds is good
I think she's good it is the part of the
movie that
would what I like that the movie
actually did that Sur surprised me was
because they were doing the whole thing
with like making fun of like fanatical
Christians right and and then they had a
moment this section of the film where
she decides to try to understand you
know she's like going to the churches
she's trying to get answers she wants to
she wants to
actually understand the point of view
yeah and I thought that was cool to
include that and they kind of go back on
that you know with the whole like AR no
and I thought I thought more would come
of that a because of that they bothered
to get him and and B that is an
interesting idea like I thought the
movie was going to give a thoughtful
yeah piece of advice from him and maybe
subvert that I liked his the joke of his
performance but I did kind of I was
maybe hoping for a little bit of like
well I have all this friction with
Amanda bins but like her dad is actually
living up to the spirit of what he's
trying to preach you know by trying to
help me out you know or something like
that and I so I I liked that she was
like searching for the point of view
which was a a real surprise um it did
become a little too cartoony for me
though at times when when they were cut
to the fanatical Christians they yeah
they are the they are a bit of a punch
line or or you could argue they're
punching a little not not in a very mean
way but they're kind of punching down
they're a th% punching down yes yeah 1
million per punches yeah when when he
whips out that guitar and the one guy
starts singing like it's funny but also
I mean yeah they are they are like
they're not giving as much of that
here's a bit of nuance and personality
to balance these people out to help you
see past The Stereotype that so many
other characters are getting the benefit
of the doubt of or and you will lose
that in a runtime sure bottom line like
you sure you will yeah pair these people
down um but for everything that we got
that is positive oh and also so I
thought that they I love the the early
jokes with the adopted kid and I like
how there's something about me that
really likes just how simple and
accepting of a situation it is like they
don't try to make a whole storyline out
of it they don't try to have these like
extra scenes they did set him up to be a
character a character though and and
nothing Becomes of that it's just it's
just oh but part of me likes that
because he is it is there is again
there's something refreshing about hey
it's it's it's not a secret it's very
open he's adopted they make fun of it
cuz he's like the black kid in the
family you know I think it yeah it's
like I think it might have to me I think
partly is the family again I know I've
said it a couple times feels a bit more
broad than some of the other characters
and elements of the movie and I think
that well they feel like hippies without
being hippies yeah without being too of
the Hipp from yeah yeah yeah they're
like high functioning adjusted hippies
and and yeah like good careers and yeah
and I thought I guess the thing with the
brother is that it becomes only that and
like that's such like a meme of their
family that I stopped thinking of him as
an actual character yeah and like their
whole their whole Rapport on screen in
this movie is just them making adoption
Jokes which is funny which is great but
I was hoping maybe that a they would
like he and Emma Stone would have some
kind of anything
scene because he clearly privy to all
this she's do at least to some extent
and maybe he doesn't understand at all
and again it's probably one of those
things you would cut for runtime but I
was kind of thinking like oh man if we
could get like a scene or a moment that
you know does something for his journey
because he's going to be walking into
you know the Lion's Den of high school
and all that soon enough you know uh I
don't know I thought yeah some kind of
bonding or some kind of other beat for
him aside from we're gonna make a few
jokes with you at the beginning and then
about third of the way through halfway
through we're not really you're just
going to be in the background if you're
here at all you know check it out for
anagrams Pendergast is an anagram for
pretend
shag I thought that's a real unique name
wasn't it yeah I've heard it it's a real
name but yes that's I bet they chose it
just for that emone had an asthma attack
during the fake sex scene oh no Amanda
binds decided to quit acting after
watching herself in this film this is
it this is the movie really say that
yeah Jennifer lawr originally audition
for the roll of olive I can see that and
then she did uh the no hard feelings no
hard feelings yes I was going to call it
sex drive but that's so apparently like
the original script this was a hard R 41
fword s word 13 times and the CW three
times um I'm just reading like
yeah this a man this was originally
going to be a super bad I I like that
this didn't have to be super bad uh yeah
yeah CU it's very much adjacent to and
it complements a movie like super bad
but I thought yeah this I don't know
this this felt like all everyone in the
family is named after food sure
okay uh yeah there's so many fun little
details it's like even though there
there might have been things I was we
you know we've talked about a couple the
gripes but I thought that for what this
movie is it felt like kind of all it
needed to be at least on like oh my God
Spider-Man connection oh was Thomas haen
Church Sam man of
course and and he was in no way home
with Andrew Garfield and he was in
Spider-Man with them and stone and now
they're connected it's perfect um but uh
but yeah like this I didn't miss the R
rating in this like at all not at all so
like I felt like intentionally PG-13
yeah and I think it works I appropriate
for it doesn't feel like they edited it
down it feels like they changed it in
the script first and then made it which
is what they did and it feels like even
though high school kids swear a lot
anyway like it felt appropriate for this
and I think the use of slang words like
[__] and other things still carry a
harshness that feels like you're doing a
real curse even if it's not the same
thing yeah you know listen John it's
really late this video please let do it
all righty guys thank you so much for
being here um be sure to uh leave your
thoughts down below what you think about
EA thank you to our sponsors a great way
to support the channel let's go support
the sponsors let them know who sent you
and uh if you're listening this on Apple
and Spotify please go ahead and rate
this video and I think that's it for
today thank you guys so much we'll talk
to you all soon
[Music]
Che